[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi consacré aux métiers
des services à la personne
sans oublier notre volet consacré à la
formation notre volet également en
recrutement sans plus tarder voici le
sommaire
focus sur l'entreprise altruiste basée à
montigny le bretonneux elle propose des
services des deux quotidiens et de
maintien au domicile
illustration chez un particulier nous
irons lycée louis-blériot attrape
l'établissement accueille depuis
septembre des stagiaires qui prépare un
diplôme d'état assistant de vie aux
familles une formation proposée par le
greta décision enfin nous évoquerons
plus largement ce secteur avec nos
invités jean pierre du jacquet sonia
anglaise de l'hymne vie une plate forme
départementale dédiée aux services à la
personne et si vous êtes d'ailleurs à la
recherche d'un emploi rendez vous à la
fin de ce numéro depuis ces dernières
années partout en france et notamment à
saint quentin en yvelines les
opportunités d'emploi sont nombreuses
dans le secteur des services à la
personne des agences comme altruiste
propose des prestations à domicile
reportage depuis plus de dix ans la
société altruiste compte deux agences
dans les yvelines
ici à montigny le bretonneux l agence
propose des services de maintien à
domicile et des deux quotidiens à mes
côtés mathieu guiberteau bonjour vous
êtes le gérant d'altruiste à leur
première question quels sont les
avantages pour des particuliers pour des
clients de faire appel à une agence
comme altruiste
nous sommes totalement
en ce mode service par rapport aux
bénéficiaires qui lui n'a aucune
responsabilité en terme de
droit du travail ou de contrainte il
peut sa seule responsabilité vis-à-vis
de nous donc il ya évidemment un contrat
qui nous lie mais il ya possibilité de
la suspende l'annuler alors comment se
déroule un recrutement vous exigez des
diplômes et des références comment ça se
passe pour le ménage pas forcément on
prend beaucoup de références encore ans
on fait attention à ce que la personne
soit de qualité et sage travailler et
une expérience dans le domaine et on se
fie beaucoup retour qu'on a de nos
bénéficiaires clients
il n'y a pas forcément de on passe plus
de l'expérience que par le diplôme dans
ce métier là al'inverse pour
l'assistance de vie aux familles il ya
des diplômes nationaux des diplômes
d'état qui qui encadrent notre activité
et que nous exigeons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marie-josée bonjour un beau show vous
êtes salarié de la société altruiste
vous êtes assistantes de vie à domicile
en quoi consiste le métier d'assistante
de vie à domicile c'est de la compagnie
on a amené à accompagner les gens dans
les gestes au courant de la vie des
choses qui peuvent plus faire où ils
sont pas en mesure de le faire
entièrement quel type d'activité
justement vous vous posez c'est très
varié on peut les amener à faire des
accompagnements de course à accompagner
la personne faire ses courses
on peut aussi intervenir pour l'aide
europa le repas du midi le dîner où le
petit déjeuner les toilettes aide à la
toilette à l'habillage ans dans l'ordre
un petit peu de nous qui nous en aurons
aussi en échange au fil des années des
mois il ya des choses qui se crée il ya
de la sympathie pour la plupart qui
seront assez seul nous sommes le seul
contact qu'ils ont avec l'extérieur
alors pour accéder à ces métiers il est
préférable de suivre une formation vous
avez peut-être déjà entendu parler des
greta ce sont des structures de
l'éducation nationale qui organise des
formations pour adultes dans la plupart
des métiers et compris les services à la
personne
direction le lycée louis blériot à
trappes nous sommes au lycée des métiers
louis blériot à trappes
depuis septembre l'établissement
accueille une formation intitulée
assistant de vie aux familles elle est
proposée par le greta des yvelines une
structure de l'éducation nationale
le greta des yvelines en fait ça
signifie groupement d'établissements
donc c'est à dire que nous réalisons des
formations la plupart du temps à
l'intention de demander un emploi dans
des établissements scolaires
nous formons également fait des salariés
à la demande d'entreprises donc nous
sommes capables effectivement de faire
des formations sur des modules très
court pour des salariés aussi des
formations plus longues et certifiantes
pour des demandes un ample ici donc
c'est la formation assistante de vie aux
familles ça consiste en quoi cette
formation alors la formation assistante
de vie aux familles en fait c'est un
titre professionnel en fait du ministère
du travail qui prépare en fait les
stagiaires à travailler en fait au
domicile de particuliers et donc de les
accompagner en fait dans les gestes du
quotidien
donc aussi bien l'aide à la toilette la
préparation de repas mais aussi l'après
en charge des enfants toujours au
domicile ce sont des formations assez
courte 1 6 mois à peu près je crois oui
cela se déroule comment il ya de la
théorie la pratique les formateurs ce
sont des souvent d'anciens
professionnels donc qui veillent
effectivement à alterner à la fois
effectivement des cours théoriques et de
la pratique il ya également deux
périodes de stages en entreprise donc il
passe une première période de stage
auprès des personnes âgées
donc soit à domicile soit aux structures
dans des ehpad par exemple et puis la
deuxième période de stage se passe
auprès des enfants puisqu'ils sont
formés à l'accompagnement de l'ensemble
de la famille aussi bien les personnes
âgées malades mais aussi effectivement
les enfants nous nous trouvons sur le
plateau technique cuisine avec caroline
bonjour bonjour est devant nous de très
beaux gâteaux alors vous avez fait en a
quelques-uns de ses gâteaux c'est dans
le cadre de votre formation assistant de
vie famille c'est bien ça absolument
alors pourquoi justement vous avez fait
des gâteaux pourquoi des gâteaux dans
cas de cette formation
alors en fait c'est pour s'entraîner
pour par la suite pendant le métier que
l'on que l'on va faire à des baisses
assistante de vie aux familles eh bien
il faut savoir cuisiner il faut savoir
entretenir le linge faut savoir faire
tout ça alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus sur votre parcours
comment vous est venu ici à faire cette
formation alors moi avant j'étais dans
la restauration dans le tourisme j'ai
fait un peu pas mal de choses et puis
j'ai décidé que j'ai décidée c'est
d'aider les gens voilà clairement c'est
ce que je préfère m'occuper des gens les
aider
à l'issue de cette formation est ce que
vous savez déjà ce que vous allez faire
ah oui j'ai déjà des contacts par la
suite pour déjà travaillé avec ed avec
des personnages à domicile on est dans
un studio qui a été mis à disposition
pour pouvoir mettre en situation d des
situations de ville de la vie de tous
les jours donc pour apprendre les gestes
éco musique etc
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans cette
formation le fait de d'aider les
personnes de se sentir utile dans ce
qu'on fait chaque année 80 stagiaires
suivent une formation du greta dans le
secteur des services à la personne
90 % d'entre eux trouvent un emploi
après obtention de leur diplôme
on va là vous en servez savez désormais
un peu plus sur les métiers des services
à la personne
alors si vous avez envie de vous lancer
dans ce secteur voici ce qu'il faut
retenir pour devenir assistant aux
assistantes de vie à domicile comme
marie josé et bien il faut suivre une
formation diplômante équivalente un ca
paix ou bep le salaire le smic horaire
l'évolution possible dans ce métier
travailleur familial à condition de
suivre une formation supplémentaire
petit plus dans ce métier la discrétion
autres métiers présents dans le secteur
des services à la personne aide médico
psychologique il faut obtenir un diplôme
d'état le salaire en début de carrière
environ 1300 euros nets
évolution possible éducateurs ou
éducatrice spécialisée qualités
demandées dans ce métier être patient
focus à présent sur une plate forme
départementale pour les services à la
personne ligne vit avec nous en plateau
jean pierre bujak et sonia antunès
bonjour a alors vous êtes tous les deux
en charge et de sécurisation des
parcours et relations entreprises au
sein de cette plateforme assez récente 1
d'ailleurs puisqu'elle existe depuis un
petit peu plus d'un an sony antunès
alors ligne vie c'est en fait la fusion
de la madone et
ici ma pensée bien c'est ce que vous
nous en dire plus tout à fait donc il ya
eu la fusion il ya environ un an donc il
vit aujourd'hui est une association qui
favorise les
qui favorise justement les unes favorise
une association qui est financé par le
département c'est bien ça c'est
exactement qui n'a vraiment pas le pas
le seul financeur mais qui favorise les
échanges de de jean pierre bussac
l'émission l'émission précise les
missions précises on l'a fait on a trois
grandes missions
une première qui est une mission auprès
des entreprises adhérentes à jeunes dont
qui sont des entreprises date à domicile
le plupart du temps on les accompagne
sur des questions comme la
professionnalisation de leur personnel
déjà déjà embauché sur la démarche
qualité aussi on est un deuxième grand
axe de travail qui est la sécurisation
des parcours donc où sonia et moi même
sommes qu'elle me sente impliqué qui
consiste en fait à accompagner des
demandeurs d'emploi
ou bénéficiaires rsa ou les deux
d'ailleurs sur des violations parcours
de professionnalisation dans ce domaine
là jusqu'à l'accès à l'emploi et on
continue être présent à côté d'eux
jusque 6 mois après qu'ils soient qui
soit un emploi après on considère qu'ils
ont plus besoin de nous et il se
débrouille tout seul
le troisième axe qui est plus récente un
axe sur l'innovation on essaye
d'anticiper en fait toutes les
évolutions qui sont qui sont liées au
monde d'aujourd'hui à savoir notamment
le numérique
voilà comment c est comment ces
évolutions la vont impacter les
pratiques professionnelles qu'est-ce que
ça va changer au niveau du
fonctionnement des entreprises des
choses comme ça présente sur tout le
département effectivement pour
finalement être au plus proche des
candidats afin de les accompagner dans
leur dans leurs projets dans ce secteur
où dans leur emploi puisque aujourd'hui
l'antre la plateforme une vieille
représente environ 120 entreprises ou
associations sur tout le département
afin de les accompagner les entreprises
sur leurs besoins en recrutement où les
candidats dans ce projet de deux
formations dans notre secteur d'activité
justement un mot sur ce sucre sur ce
secteur c'est vrai qu'on entend beaucoup
parler ces dernières années des des
services à la personne est ce que vous
avez pu voir vous cette évolution tout à
fait alors il faut savoir que c'est un
secteur aujourd'hui qui est qui se
professionnalise de plus en plus donc il
ya de plus en plus de nouvelles
formations existantes sur ce secteur sur
l'année 2010 est on a pu justement
obtenir une réforme sur le crp petite
enfance sur le diplôme aides
médico-psychologiques aujourd'hui qui a
fusionné avec l'ancien diplôme également
auxiliaire de vie sociale aujourd'hui
qui s'appelait le dea es ans donc le
diplôme d'état d'accompagnement éducatif
et social
donc le rôle de la plate forme in vie
c'est vraiment de renseigner sur toutes
ces thématiques là les candidats mais
également les employeurs jean-pierre
déjà que vous vous êtes notamment
spécialisée j'ai envie de dire donc si
on domaine de sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
vous justement vous avez vu cette
évolution aussi sur ces métiers qui sont
bien présents ici sur cette mythique sur
effectivement très présent sur le tas
les toits de 51 bien évidemment mais sur
les évidences général je crois qu'il
faut signaler que ce sont des métiers en
tension notamment aides à domicile et
aides ménagères il faut savoir qu'il ya
aujourd'hui sont ses intentions alors je
vous explique éloïse en fait sont dans
leur faut savoir que dans le le collège
de l'es12 métiers les plus recherchés
sur les yvelines son deuxième position
effectivement aides ménagères et mon
aide à domicile et que trois
recrutements sur cinq sont jugés
difficiles pour les employeurs donc
voilà donc on a vraiment des besoins
forts de personnel dans ces métiers là
et donc voilà donc c'est vraiment des
métiers qu'il faut qu'il faut encourager
encourager à investir et aujourd'hui
c'est c'est vraiment amitié en tout cas
un secteur qu'on va choisir
on n'a pas su faire puisqu'il faut pas
oublier qu'on à s'occuper de personnes
fragilisées qui auront de certaines
pathologies ou non et donc voilà c'est
ce qu'on recherche et c'est ce que
défend aujourd'hui la plateforme minfi
en essayant de valoriser au mieux ses
métiers à lille pour entrer en contact
avec vous un site internet c'est encore
le nom du sima pan donc ces trois w cie
maps 78 point fr cela s'affiche en bas
de votre écran merci à tous les deux
d'avoir été présent sur ce plateau
alors justement parlé il ya quelques
instants un de recrutement justement si
vous êtes à la recherche d'un emploi et
bien voici une offre proposée par
l'entreprise centre services à non pas à
vos stylos
je suis cédric barras gérant de lagence
centre service à mon repas
tout d'abord centre services c'est un
réseau de en pleine croissance de plus
de 70 agences sur toute la france
dédiée au secteur du service à la
personne nous intervenons régulièrement
chez nos clients afin de les accompagner
sur leurs tâches ménagères du quotidien
chez centre service mon repas nous
recrutons en local et en cdi des postes
d'employés de ménage afin de répondre à
une demande croissante de nouveaux
clients
si vous avez de l'expérience dans
l'entretien du domicile que vous êtes
sur saint quentin en yvelines et que
vous avez le sens du service
alors venez nous rencontrer et si vous
êtes une entreprise vous pouvez
évidemment nous envoyer vos offres à
l'adresse qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro à merci
de l'avoir suivi et je vous souhaite
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année
[Musique]
[Rires]